مع توجيه هيئه المحلفين في محكمه نيويورك
تهمه جنائيه للرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب تساؤلات عديده طرحت حول
مستقبله السياسي وهل ستسقط الاتهامات
الموجهه له في حال فوزه في الانتخابات
سنبدا مع صحيفه عن العديد من الخبراء في
القانون اشارت الى ان القضيه الموجهه
لترامب يمكن ان تستمر لشهور او حتى سنوات
بعض الخبراء القانونيين يرون بان قضيه
ترامب الجنائيه لن تؤثر على ترشيحه
للانتخابات ويمكن ان يخرجها عن مسارها اذا
فاز واصبح رئيسا مره اخرى فالدستور لا
يمنع متهما من الترشح للرئاسات ومع ذلك
اوضح بعض الخبراء القانونيين الاخرين
لمجله نيوزويك انه نظرا لان هذه هي المره
الاولى التي يتم فيها توجيه تهم جنائيه
لرئيس سابق فمن غير المعروف كيف ستسير
القضيه اذا اصبح رئيسا في منصبه وهو ما
يطرح تساؤلات حول النظريه القانونيه
الجديده التي سيتم اعتمادها في التعامل مع
ترامب خصوصا وان هذه النقطه تحديدا هي سبب
التاخر في اصدار لائحه الاتهام